The Tarte Fake Awake.
It is absolutely worth it.
Look at how much more bright and awake and like.
And it comes in the trio of their best selling items.
This is also their tubing mascara.
I cannot wait to pull it off,
but it really does extend your lashes.
It's so worth it to get the fake way because in the trio,
because you're getting these other two best sellers
that I didn't even know I wanted.
Look, watch,
watch how my eye goes from there.
It so creamy. It goes on really easily
and like, boom,
it gives you that little, like, dough eyed,
like Disney princessy look.
It's super worth it.
I love it.
And it even has a little sponge on the bottom that you can blend.
And then it comes with the mascara and the lip vinyl.
Let's try that one too.
I love that you click it up.
Oh, that's pretty.
Oh,
okay.
She's ready for the day with those bright eyes.